à force de chanter on est en demies
cette fois ci nous y sommes au stade de
france à saint-denis 80000 spectateurs
et des dizaines de millions de
téléspectateurs s'apprête à encourager
l'équipe de france qui rencontre la
croatie le stade est en train de se
remplir petit à petit qui fait beau les
conditions idéales pour un match pour
nous espérons tous objectivement et
qu'il tournera en notre faveur ce serait
la première fois dans l'histoire de la
coupe du monde que la france disputera
une finale
madame monsieur bonsoir nous n'en sommes
pas encore là pour l'instant les équipes
se préparent les français sont arrivés
au sade en autocar
comme d'habitude yann lavoix sur place
vers 18 heures une foule de supporters
la fin des privilèges qu'ils font que
700 habitants et bien s'étaient donné
rendez-vous à la grille du parc
tout le monde a compris que ce 8 juillet
est absolument primordial pour le foot
français
ce sera sans doute un jour historique et
puis voilà l'arrivée maintenant au stade
de france comme à l'accoutumée une bonne
heure et demie avant le début du match
regardez encore du public qui s'est
massée pour accueillir les français pour
les encourager pour ce match qui est
vraiment vous le savez maintenant
historique pour les français si on
pouvait enfin atteindre une finale de
coupe du monde ce sera peut-être tout à
l'heure dans une heure et demie en tout
cas pour pour faire ce match pour le
réussir aimé jacquet a reconduit
l'équipe qui avait joué contre l'italie
aucun changement vous allez le voir avec
barthez dans les bus la défense
habituelle lizarazu thuram desailly
blanc le milieu de terrain très
surchargé karembeu deschamps petit j
surchargé en fait un joueur de plus
comme contre l'italie c'est karembeu
tout simplement parce qu'il faudra privé
les croates de ballons afin justement de
pourvoir les attaquants de bons ballons
d'attaqué et on attaque on retrouvera
justement dix vaches et zidane et
djorkaeff à noter aussi que dugarry est
sur la feuille de match les joueurs
français ont compris et depuis longtemps
qu'ils tiennent peut-être leur destin en
main la génération 98 rêve de dépasser
ses devancières la génération de 58 la
génération de 80 de la génération de 86
et laurent blanc didier deschamps ou
aimé jacquet que vous allez entendre
dans un instant nous n'en dise pas plus
il dit simplement on s'était tous donné
rendez vous le 12 juillet c'est à dire
dimanche au stade de france pour la
finale
on y est presque il faut juste qu'on
gagne sept matches et bien il faut
gagner déjà ce soir écouter laurent
blanc tout d'abord un pari de gagner
sept matches bon il nous en reste deux à
deux à gagner
mais avant de penser au dernier il faut
passer d'abord à suivre se concentrer au
maximum que sur celui là et puis être
certaines de nos forces de nos qualités
et pouvoir se dire qu'on peut passer ce
test lab on sait ce que qu'a connue ce
pays avec la guerre les déchirements qui
a eu et on sent qu'à travers ses joueurs
il n'y a pas qu'un match de football il
représente toute une nation et
l'entraîneur blasé vichy est pour
beaucoup là-dedans il s'est donné
de l'importance il sait faire faire
passer à ses joueurs ce message de se
sentir encore plus important dans leur
pays bien entendu avec l'étude de de
l'organisation de cette belle équipe
crois tu es bien nous aurons un plan de
jeu un plan de jeu qui menait passé
serment en fonction de tel ou tel joueur
mais surtout en fonction de la manière
dont cette équipe manoeuvre parce
qu'elle a plusieurs
plusieurs je dirais chef d'orchestre et
c'est ce qui la rend un petit peu
redoutable donc nous aurons un plan de
jeu qui sera adapté à cette situation
c'est qu'il de france est restée
invisible aujourd'hui ce ne fut pas le
cas des croates ce matin dans leur
retraite en région parisienne ils sont
allés au devant leurs supporters et ils
ont reçu la visite de leur président en
rouge man florent gautreau philippe
deslandes
ils sont les seigneurs du château les
croates préparent leur match dans le
cadre rustique du château de la tour à
quelques kilomètres de chantilly la
crème des footballeurs se réveille tout
doucement les coups de fil de zagreb
font monter la pression mais il en faut
plus pour inquiéter les vainqueurs de
l'allemagne
et comme on s'ennuie un peu on n'hésite
pas à s'échapper hasanovic a donné
rendez vous à l'extérieur à des amis
pénard mais pas bavard vous avez bien
dormi ça fait s'il ne s'est pas son
entraîneur va nous le dire
jamais avare de confidences blasé beach
et de sortie sont bien
crispés les joueurs croates difficile à
croire toute la matinée ils se sont
succédé devant les grilles du château
pour discuter avec les supporters
jarny avait même retrouvé sa compagne et
toute la belle famille à 10 heures du
match les croates sont confiants et
optimistes
on va gagner de toute façon je n'aime
pas perdre
à l'intérieur on a mis les petits plats
dans les grands
les joueurs attendent le grand soir mais
aussi le président de la croatie franjo
tudjman est passé saluer les joueurs
rien de tel qu'une demi finale de coupe
du monde pour réapparaître sur
l'échiquier international
l'après-midi s'écoule tranquillement les
joueurs font la sieste avant de monter
dans le bus qui va les amener au stade
de france
au bout du chemin il y as peut-être un
nouvel exploit
surprise de ce mondial dans les mois qui
ont précédé des allergiques au football
nous avait prédit une augmentation des
scènes de ménage voir des divorces
pendant la compétition et bien on s'est
aperçu que parmi les téléspectateurs de
la coupe du monde il y avait plus de 30%
de femmes
à commencer bien entendu par les
premières intéressées des épouses
respectives des joueurs de l'équipe de
france sophie mais z
jean-paul chaussée petite ambiance en
cette fin d'après midi devant le siège
de la fédération française de football
avenue d'iéna à paris une poignée de
supporteurs qui semble égarée
et pourtant non ceux là savent que c'est
ici comme avant chaque match que les
femmes et fiancée de joueurs se donnent
rendez-vous pour partir ensemble au
stade de france acclamer leurs héros
frédéric dugarry va ni à l'ama et claude
deschamps respecte le mot d'ordre de la
fédération
la discrétion pas un mot de filtres de
ce côté là bonjour vous allez bien
alors que bon ça va ça va bien
al'approche l'animatrice tant décrié
ben on commence à la pression mais ça va
aller
votre mari au téléphone ou pas il a la
pression forcément mais ça va
ben
ça ne dit pas vous avez eu votre mari
est allé me sens bien salaire qu'est ce
que voulez vous souhaitez là bon courage
tous avaient décrit grille il a quelque
chose à vous sur lui for almost quelque
chose
oui
je pense qu'il va voir le roi sait que
sa fille accompagnée au poignet
éventuellement traiter une question mise
42e adriana est aussi connu pour son
record personnel une longueur de jambes
faramineuses un maître 24 c'est toujours
le même rituel vous savez moi je lui
souhaite bonne chance et lui il me
répond tout va bien on va gagner ce soir
après le match
on leur a tout promis quelques
précieuses minutes d'intimité avec l'as
rome
cette solide et devrait amener ces
messieurs souhaitons le à se dépasser
sur la pelouse il y aura ce soir 22
joueurs 11 de part et d'autre pour
chaque équipe
un douzième homme le douzième homme et
bien en fait ce sont les supporters les
joueurs en ont besoin ils motivent
encore un peu plus nos champions ils
leur sont indispensables album nicosie
l'udc va chauffer selon l'expression
consacrée l'équipe de france compte sur
un douzième homme
son public douzième homme voire dix ans
plus tôt 11 et demi
hull enthousiasme modéré observé à vos
abords du stade
il a été à marseille assure brésil pays
bas et seront là fruits en progrès et
hollandais j'en arrive il ya aucun
français on a l'impression qu'on aime
bacon qu'on vous fait pas la coupe du
monde chez nous
nous vivons en france les supporters
croates qui seront faits de wismes il
semble pour l'heure plus démonstratif
oui c'est très important pour nous
d'abord et ses couleurs ses les couleurs
de la nation presque tout le monde a dit
shirt comme nous à la différence des
clubs dont les supporters forment des
groupes constitués
l'équipe de france doit composer avec un
public moins habitué aux grands matches
internationaux à l'épuisement
c'est à mourir comme eux et c'est qu'ils
envisagent la 2 0 pour la france sans
problème 2 0 pour la france il serait
temps alors d'afficher sa fierté de
rejoindre paris pour un autre match
la nuit la plus folle laurent falaize
ball et que nous retrouverons justement
devant les portes du grand stade de
saint-denis
laurent est ce que vous sentez les
supporters confiant dans l'équipe de
france mais tout à fait daniel mais pour
compléter le sujet qu'on vient de voir
c'est vrai que dans ce premier match
peut-être qui précède le grand match des
supporters les croates ont marqué des
points puisque les croates viennent
peut-être à 10000 avec à chaque fois
leur fameux maillot à damier rouge et
blanc
et c'est vrai que les français n'ont pas
toujours cette couleur bleue qui
pourrait les identifier alors hier nous
étions à marseille vous en souvenez pour
cette première demi finale pays bas
brésil et c'est vrai qu'on avait vu
toute la journée
vingt mille personnes en jaune et 20000
personnes en orange au moins c'était
identifier c'est vrai que les supporters
français n'ont pas toujours la tenue je
dirais réglementaire de l'équipe de
france
en tout état de cause vous savez aussi
qu'au niveau des supporters en france
parfois effectivement le public est
plutôt spectateur que supporters et la
manière de gagner souvent importe plus
que le résultat même alors on verra bien
ce soir ce que ça donnerait on peut
quand même penser que pour une demi
finale de coupe du monde
seize ans jour pour jour après la
fameuse demi-finale de séville
on peut quand même penser que les 70000
française qui seront là pour sauter
équipe de france feront enfin du bruit
et seront vraiment derrière cette équipe
de france daniel merci laurent si la
france on touche du bois parce le cadre
des demi finales elle aura vaincu le
signe indien qui par trois fois l'en
avait empêché en 58 ans 82 ans 86
cristal bertrand vendredi 3 juillet 98
saint denis
la france passe son tour in extremis et
se retrouve en demi finale de la coupe
du monde
la joie et la réussite d'un groupe qu'on
retrouve 30 ans plus tôt en suède
tambour pantoufles et maracas annonce le
match contre le brésil c'est la première
fois que la france atteint une
demi-finale de coupe du monde 24 juin
1958 stockton pelé âgé de 17 ans inscrit
trois des cinq buts brésiliens
la france s'incline finalement 5 2
depuis ce match juste fontaine et dans
les livres
jamais personne n'a égalisé 13 buts
marqués en coupe du monde l'équipe de
france de l'époque n'a pas eu de chance
jonquet le capitaine se casse la jambe
et la france finit à dix contre onze
mais le brésil était plus fort ces gens
qui n'avaient pas été blessés
si on avait dû comme aujourd'hui
remplacer le joueur
tout était possible avec des si on
devient aujourd hui juillet 80 de civils
face à l'allemagne de schumacher
michel platini égalisent sur penalty 1
partout et les français ce m'est arrivé
trois minutes après le début des
prolongations à la jsr marius trésor
la france prend une longueur d'avancé
cinq minutes plus tard alain giresse
ouvrant grand la porte de la finale
en plus j'ai vu ce qui s'est passé c'est
un tournoi non je pense surtout qu'il ya
une telle angoisse moment là qu on a eu
du mal à maîtriser justement et
peut-être qu'il vaut mieux ne pas se
souvenir de ce match
schumacher agressent bâtissons
l'allemand ne prend pas de carton jaune
l'allemagne revient au score et la
france s'incline aux tirs au but la
légende des france-allemagne aîné 25
juin 86
guadalajara mexique l'histoire se répète
demi finale france allemagne
un parfum de revanche mais les bleus
sont fatigue la bande à platini perd
finalement 2-0 passe complètement à côté
du match et d'une finale de coupe du
monde aujourd'hui les bleus ont bien
changé balayé les trois échecs
successifs oublier les erreurs passées
de toute façon jamais trois sans quatre
ça n'existe pas parlons maintenant un
peu des croates pour les croates qui
vivent une aventure historique c'est
également la mobilisation de tout un
peuple des milliers de supporters sont
arrivés en france cet après midi par
avion spécial
philippe visseyrias josé boulesteix sur
place impossible de ne pas remarquer la
famille chimique ch dans l'aéroport de
zagreb
madame porte fièrement le numéro 20 le
même que son fils au sein de l'équipe
nationale croate
ce soir dario chimici s'apprête à
disputer le match le plus important de
sa vie un moment unique que la famille
va vivre depuis les tribunes du stade de
france
je n'en reviens pas
c'est la première fois que je prends
l'avion la première fois que je vais à
paris la première fois que je vois un
match de la coupe du monde et en plus
c'est mon frère qui joue ce cas là je
sens et pas assez d'action
cela représente tant de choses pour
notre pays elle a souffert de la guerre
à 22 ans dario chimici a été samedi
dernier l'un des artisans de la victoire
historique de la croatie sur l'allemagne
ses exploits iosif son petit frère les
connaît par coeur et sait les repas sans
cesse après le match contre l'allemagne
dario l'a appelé un coup de téléphone
qu'il n'oubliera jamais
ornella cas il est faite reine quasi
griller tout le temps il disait c'est
pas vrai c'est incroyable ce qu'on a
fait il lui a fallu une heure pour
pouvoir parler you zip et footballeurs
comme son frère il joue au croatie à
zagreb plus connu sous le nom de dynamos
avant la partition de la yougoslavie
la grand-mère encourage toujours ses
petits fils à sa façon moi je prie après
tant de sacrifices
dieu a enfin donné la victoire à la
croatie par superstition il aux iep est
allé jeter une pièce dans une fontaine
du centre de zagreb qui parait-il exauce
tous les voeux pour la croatie nouvel
état indépendant depuis l'éclatement de
la yougoslavie dans les année 80 12
la présence en demi-finale de la coupe
du monde n'est pas simplement faut
comprendre une aventure sportive c'est
également sur le plan politique un moyen
de faire reconnaître un pays dont le
régime n'est pas franchement
démocratique philippe visseyrias josé
boulesteix vue kovar cimetière de
nouveaux groupes liés ces images ont été
diffusées il ya quelques jours par la
télévision croate
chaque samedi depuis deux mois les
martyrs de la nation croate jeté pendant
la guerre dans des fosses communes sont
enterrées lors de cérémonies solennelles
même si la guerre est terminée en
croatie les cicatrices ne sont pas
encore refermées
aujourd'hui à zagreb porter les couleurs
nationales revêt une dimension
particulière fier d'être croate
le slogan est arboré sans détour les
croates sont fiers ça a toujours été
comme ça c'est plus qu'un succès sportif
c'est un succès sur tous les plans
nous sommes un pays jeune c'est la
meilleure des promotions pour nous ces
jours ci le damier rouge et blanc
symbole de la croatie est présent dans
toutes les rues de zagreb
une communion derrière l'équipe
nationale que le parti au pouvoir celui
du président tout man encourage bien
volontiers même les représentants de la
minorité serbe semble rallier à la cause
des footballeurs rouge et blanc c'est
positif sur sa montre et d'identité
nationale
c'est un signe pacifique c'est important
pour le peuple
one illustration de cet engouement
l'unique quotidien sportif du pays a
doublé ses ventes depuis le début de la
coupe du monde on peut comparer cet
événement aux trois étapes de la
construction du pays
c'est à dire sa reconnaissance
internationale et les deux batailles
territoriale gagné par les croates dans
la province de la krajina invite de
soutien et de reconnaissance
internationale
la croatie a trouvé en ces footballeurs
des ambassadeurs plus efficace que tous
les diplomates à 40 minutes du match
maintenant nous retrouvons en direct de
zagreb philippe visseyrias quelle est
l'atmosphère en ce moment dans la
capitale
eh bien ça monte ça monte tout doucement
nous sommes ici sur la place de la
république française est un clin d'oeil
de l'actualité et c'est ici qu'on a
installé un écran géant
alors pour l'instant les supporters
croates ne sont pas très nombreux vous
l'entendez derrière moi on n'entend plus
la sono que leurs champs c'est vrai
qu'il a plu sur zagreb aujourd'hui cela
a peut être découragé du monde
ce qui est sûr c'est que les supporters
froide se verrait bien battre la france
ce matin le quotidien sportif titrait en
une
nous jouerons la finale vous voyez qu'il
ne doute de rien c'est vrai que si la
victoire sur l'allemagne avait été vécue
comme une belle surprise
on attend maintenant simplement une
confirmation c'est qui ce qui est sûr
c'est que ce soir en principe la quasi
totalité de la population sera devant
son poste de télévision et sondages ont
montré que près de 95 % des croates
avaient regardé le match contre
l'allemagne ce sera difficile de faire
mieux mais qui sait nous sommes ici dans
un pays qui est vraiment passionné de
football
merci philippe l'équipe qui l'emportera
ce soir rencontrera dimanche en finale
le brésil qui hier soir a battu les
pays-bas aux tirs au but au terme d'un
match qui s'était achevé sur le score de
1 partout et c'est frank de boer qui a
tremblé au moment de tirer son penalty
les hollandais ont raté par deux fois
leurs tirs au but c'était suffisant pour
que les brésiliens l'emploi fait que
mario zagallo après les larmes de boer
écrase eu aussi une petite larme tout de
suite après comme on les imagine ce fut
le signal du début de la fête dans tout
le brésil sur place christophe duchiron
franck vaillant petit du corps culte de
l'effort de ce point de vue là le
brésilien de la plage d'ipanema
ressemble aux californiens de los
angeles
il est vrai qu'après la fête d'hier soir
un peu de gymnastique ne peut pas faire
de mal ce matin le brésil s'est réveillé
en finale et la finale les brésiliens ne
pense qu'à ce peu importe l'adversaire
le brésil va gagner
j'aimerais bien que ce soit la croatie
en finale parce que les 36 ans beaucoup
de supporters même si les français sont
nos amis il va falloir qu'on les bat on
va prier pour que le brésil soit
vainqueur quel que soit l'adversaire en
matière de prière le supporteur
brésilien ne s'est pas prévenu hier soir
pendant la prolongation à rio c'est des
êtres dame de la consternation
un parking au sport alors mieux vaut
s'en remettre à dieu et à c'est vous
c'est maintenant les premiers penalty le
calvaire du supporters les nerfs à fleur
de peau yolanda viennent de marquer
désolation
le temps passe vite et paradoxalement
cette interminable et puis soudain pris
le s'embrase c'est notre dame de la
résurrection
le brésil vainqueur la sarabande un peu
folle des enfants du paradis 150
millions de brésiliens villa de la coupe
du monde
la rue était d'un stade c'est désormais
une piste de danse la danse des petits
par et décors qui en guise d'appel
angoisses de l'élimination ce qu'est la
samba la nuit heureuse des cariocas
actuellement sur la pelouse du stade de
france à saint-denis
l'équipe de france et son gardien
barthez sont en train de s'échauffer
comme vous le voyez sur ces images qui
nous parviennent en direct
l'échauffement donc à un peu plus de 40
minutes du coup d'envoi de cette demi
finale contre la croatie barthès qui a
sauvé la france contre l'italie vendredi
dernier sur lequel on compte beaucoup ce
soir
et voilà cette soirée de fête ne doit
pas nous faire oublier le gendarme
français daniel nivel grièvement blessé
par un hooligan allemand à lens
aujourd'hui sur le pont de l'europe à
strasbourg une délégation de policiers
allemands est venu remettre à leurs
collègues français des milliers de
messages de sympathie
pendant ce temps là à lille où il est
hospitalisé dans le coma daniel nivel et
sa famille ont reçu la visite du
ministre allemand du travail est
l'occasion pour les médecins d'établir
son dernier bulletin de santé ses fans
guez patrick d'émules un ministre
allemand au chevet du gendarme daniel
nivel avant tout une visite symbolique
pour soutenir la famille et exprimer la
mauvaise conscience d'un pays
le chancelier kohl utilisé lui le terme
de honte nationale
des millions et des millions et mes
compatriotes éprouve de la compassion
pour la famille de mission
yves elle moi je les dis à la famille
des nations elle et je lui ai dit aussi
les meilleurs sentiments mais sur le
chancelier fédéral
les allemands ont en effet été très
choqués par ces images du gendarme
étendu le soir du 21 juin après son
agression par des hooligans allemands
hospitalisé en urgence daniel nivel est
toujours dans le coma
mais selon les médecins il serait sorti
de la phase la plus critique situation
s'améliore en ce qui concerne le niveau
de commun mais nous ne pouvons pas
encore aujourd'hui dire dans quels
délais nous obtiendrons la sortie du
coma ce qui pour nous est définie par
l'exécution d'un ordre simple lorsqu'on
examine le patient pour l'instant les
médecins se déclare toujours incapable
de répondre à ces deux questions
essentielles
quand daniel nivel sortira-t-il du coma
et avec quelles séquelles avant de
revenir à la coupe du monde les autres
grands titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi dans les calanques près de
marseille et dans les quartiers sud de
la ville depuis cet après midi le
mistral attise le premier incendie
vraiment sérieux de l'été mille pompiers
sont mobilisés 300 personnes ont déjà
été évacuées
il ya un écart aussi derrière ces barres
rocheuses il y a les calanques les
joyaux de la côte marseillaise deux
incendies cet après-midi et plus de 350
hectares détruits des conditions de
lutte très difficile pour les moyens
aériens
le feu a démarré à la cayolle avant de
se propager vers sormiou morgiou il
s'étant pas en largeur mais
malheureusement la progression vers la
mer continue continuer surtout du côté
de la calanque de morgiou et devant la
menace
les autorités ont décidé d'évacuer mort
jouer sur mu 360 personnes dont 115
enfants ont été ramenés en bateau
jusqu'au port de cassy puis en bus vers
marseille laissant les calanques en
proie aux flammes
à l'autre bout du département à mouriès
d'importants moyens aériens sont
mobilisés pour endiguer un incendie qui
s'étend sur une cinquantaine d'hectares
mais la tâche des pompiers est difficile
les sautes de feu sont nombreuses et les
mistral soufflait toujours
tous les magistrats parisiens concernés
par les affaires de terrorisme en corse
étaient réunis aujourd'hui à bastia
déplacement à la fois symboliques mais
discret pour montrer la détermination du
gouvernement à résoudre notamment le
mystère de l'assassinât du préfet
erignac pascal nous c'est bon dominique
merde à défaut d'être discrète l'arrivée
des magistrats parisiens au palais de
justice était muette
personne ici ne souhaite faire de
commentaire c'est l'élite judiciaire de
la lutte antiterroriste qui est venu à
bastia aujourd'hui l'élite
c'est à dire jean louis bruguière juge
d'instruction jean pierre dintilhac
procureur de la république de paris et
irène scolaire chef de la 14e section du
parquet la 14e section dont
l'omniprésence en matière de terrorisme
est critiquée par de nombreux avocats
corses la colonne section à une une
tendance à l'impérialisme judiciaire en
corse par le biais d'une
incrimination très discutable qui est ce
l association de malfaiteurs très
extensible
les magistrats corse aussi sont
mécontents dans le cadre de l enquête
sur l'assassinât du préfet claude
erignac
l'un personnes ont été interpellées dans
des procédures menées depuis paris comme
le prévoit la loi de 86 les juges et
procureurs de lille se sentent un peu
oublié depuis quelques jours les
magistrats corses ont tout fait pour
éviter la polémique mais ils souhaitent
être mieux informés mieux associées aux
enquêtes sur le terrorisme d'où leur
volonté d'organiser cette première
réunion ici à bastia mais ils le
promettent d'autres sommets du même
genre ont lieu dans un avenir proche à
paris ou ailleurs un nouveau moyen au
service des antennes assedic pour les
demandeurs d'emploi des visio guichet en
direct grâce à la télévision sans avoir
à se déplacer
il est désormais possible de constituer
donc à distance son dossier reporte à
juliette beau daniel bbc pour l'inscrire
au chômage pourrait presque devenir
ludique dans cette association des saint
denis en banlieue parisienne ce jeu de
chômeurs expérimente un nouveau service
le visio guichet discussion et qui va
répondre à toutes les questions de tubes
de l'autre côté de l'écran les assedic
200 points c'est à quelques kilomètres
pas la peine de se déplacer on converse
à distance
enfin on essaye ça serait pour une
raison simple
je me refuse ça serait pour une
réinscription en hausse du cac après
inscription ou demandes de dossiers le
système présente surtout un avantage le
gain de temps 15 minutes au lieu de
quelques jours par la poste
chacun y trouve son compte
dont on traite en direct les
informations et les dossiers pour
l'instant une dizaine de visio guichet
d'expérimenter à saint-denis et dans
quelques départements ruraux
l'initiative pourrait être étendu à
l'ensemble de la france et faciliter des
démarches administratives souvent
contraignante pour les chômeurs merci
appuyé sur far document on ne sait pas
encore ce que recouvrir à l'impôt sur la
fortune revu et corrigé mais on sait
déjà que ce qui inquiétait le plus les
entrepreneurs n'y figurera pas à savoir
l'évaluation de l'outil de travail dans
le calcul de cet impôt et si le drapeau
américain flottait sur la tour eiffel
c'est possible la société qui gère le
monument le plus visité de france et le
crédit foncier qui est actuellement à
vendre et pour l'instant il n'y a qu'un
seul acheteur potentiel c'est une
société américaine dominique barrouche
jean-jacques le garrec
elle part en balade l'entouré scène en
balade séguy comme une chanson de
charles trenet mais la tour eiffel
racheté par les américains ici cela ne
fait sourire personne pour l'impression
qu'on voit là un peu de patrimoine les
touristes se montrent réticents les
touristes hippique française parisien et
moi je veux pas imaginer américain ce
serait vraiment dommage d'en arriver là
one pass concert au coeur du problème
l'éventuel rachat du crédit foncier de
france par la filiale financière de
general motors
or le crédit foncier au travers d'une
cascade de participations détient 70% de
la sagi qui gère entre autres la tour
eiffel certains élus s'en inquiète un
peu de la france partout dans le monde
et ce qui peut changer c'est que la
gestion n'est pas nécessairement la même
entre un service public entre l'accueil
est peut-être une gestion plus
commercial avec un partenaire que nous
n'avons pas choisi un la mairie de paris
qui reste propriétaire de l'édifice
on minimise les risques de dérapage
contrôle de la nomination du directeur
reversement des bénéfices et cahier des
charges très strict c'est tout la verse
en quelque sorte ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer si c'était effectivement une
jeune mc donald's dans tout ça on ne
pourrait pas l'accepter
le dernier mot reviendra au ministère
des finances qui n'exclut pas de retirer
la s'agit de la vente du crédit foncier
parce que la tour eiffel aux américains
c'est un peu le monde à l'envers
c'est un sénateur jean pierre raffarin
qui présente un projet de loi pour
renforcer la sécurité autour des
piscines particulière devant le nombre
relativement important de noyades
d'enfants
il propose que soit rendue obligatoire
un système de barrières autour de ces
piscines olivier théron et didier
beaumont la piscine c'est l'endroit de
jeu par excellence pour les enfants mais
c'est aussi un danger permanent
les statistiques le montrent la noyade
est la deuxième cause de mortalité chez
les moins de 4 ans en quelques minutes
seulement
généralement en fin d'après-midi le
drame peut se produire après c'est déjà
trop tard ou presque il faut
immédiatement prodigué les premiers
secours
si l'enfant est inconscient et s'il ne
respire pas aux pratiques et le bouche à
bouche et nez et si son père ne m'a pas
mettre en route
massage cardiaque et cela il faut le
faire jusqu'à l'arrivée des secours
organisés les pompiers interviennent en
quelques minutes ils vont essayer de
redonner vie à l'enfant en le libérant
les voies respiratoires
grâce à un masque à oxygène le médecin
va réaliser une incubation qui va
permettre d'avoir un accès plus direct
du poumon on pourra envoyer toujours
maximum d'oxygène
oxy jeunes et trouver ensemble et
ensuite comme cette phase là est
terminée que nous préparons qu'on
transporte à ce moment là nous avons
fait intervenir un respirateur qui lui
va réguler automatiquement les rythmes
respiration et ainsi de continuer à
l'animation pendant 3 pour éviter tout
ça avec bien souvent le décès de
l'enfant ou de graves séquelles
il faut être vigilant les enfants
doivent aussi porter des bouées ou des
brassards et la piscine doit être
protégée par des barrières de sécurité
aux états unis d'amérique cela a été mis
en place depuis de nombreuses années et
ça de toutes les études ont démontré que
statistiquement il y avait une chute
vertigineuse des noyades en piscines
celle le projet de loi donnerait
l'obligation d'installer ces barrières
sur toutes les piscines privées le
surcoût serait alors de 8000 francs
un prix élevé mais qui permettrait
d'éliminer 90 % des noyades l'actualité
internationale avec des manifestations
dans les rues de lagos au nigeria après
la mort accidentelle des suites d'une
crise cardiaque du principal opposant au
régime militaire moshood abiola élu
démocratiquement en 1993 il devait
prochainement sortir de prison
le nigeria qui vient également de perdre
le chef de sa dictature militaire le
général abacha dont les journaux
américains affirment qu'il a été victime
de la nouvelle pilule viagra qui
améliore les performances sexuelles
richard binet
ils sont descendus dans la rue pour
crier leur haine du pouvoir militaire
parce qu'ils ne croient pas à la mort
accidentelle de leur leader moshood
abiola certains y ont même laissé leur
vie onze morts selon le dernier bilan
officiel
car pour ces jeunes mt au comme on
l'appelle là-bas c'était plus qu'un chef
un modèle l'homme le plus riche du
nigeria avec son jet privé
ces quatre femmes c'est 40 automobile
ses gardes du corps habillés à la
californienne symbolisait le rêve
nigérian personnellement je pense avoir
trouvé la formule du succès et je
voudrais aujourd'hui l'appliquer à mon
pays impliqués cette règle de 10,6
clément ont rigueur qui consiste à se
tailler un costume avec ce qu'on a comme
tisseur
avec ses formules simples et son
l'éternel boubou chief m quéau abiola
était devenu le symbole de l'opposition
démocratique dans un pays dominé depuis
35 ans par les militaires campagne à
l'américaine en 1993 abiola se
présentent aux premières élections
démocratiques autorisés par le pouvoir
il est régulièrement élu mais la junte
annuler le scrutin et le jette en prison
depuis la mort le 8 juin dernier du
général abacha l'ex-homme fort du pays m
quéau abiola pouvait librement rencontré
des diplomates
les américains pour la plupart soucieux
d'asseoir leur influence sur un pays de
100 millions d'habitants aux immenses
ressources pétrolières la mort aura sans
doute privé abiola de son dernier rôle
président du nigeria et les américains
d'une pièce maîtresse dans leurs
ambitions africaines
en bref encore contre l'avis des
américains et des israéliens les
palestiniens de l'ol paie ont obtenu un
siège de super observateur aux nations
unies qui leur donne presque rang de
délégations officielles
retour sur la coupe du monde de football
le stade le grand stade de saint-denis
est en train vous voyez de copieusement
se remplir je vous rassure il n'y a plus
de places à vendre
on est à guichet fermé à une demi heure
maintenant du coup d'envoi parmi les
spectateurs du stade de france ce soir
des jeunes venus du monde entier grâce à
un concours organisé par les alliances
françaises implantées à l'étranger
pour certains c'est une aventure et un
rêve c'est le cas de quatre jeunes
pakistanais qui n'avait jamais imaginé
ce voyage lorsque nos envoyés spéciaux
philippe rochot jean françois renaud les
ont rencontrés avant leur départ
aïcha et zarka assisteront à la finale
de la coupe du monde avec trois autres
étudiants pakistanais elles ont remporté
le concours organisé par les alliances
françaises à travers le globe qui
permettra à quelques 700 jeunes de voir
l'apothéose du mondial le français est
en vogue au pakistan pays surtout
anglophone mais la france exerce une
certaine fascination sur cette terre
d'islam
coincé entre l'inde et l'iran pour
ayesha l'apprentissage de notre langue
était une sorte d'évasion
et puis je me suis beaucoup
d'alternatives toulalan oui je suis très
amoureuse zarka elle ne sera pas dépaysé
en france sa famille a choisi un mode de
vie à l'occidentale mais pas forcément
bien considéré dans son pays
si vous regardez autour de vous vous
allez voir la plupart des femmes à la
tête et moi je suis là c'est là
peut-être à genoux deux pas dans la rue
pas la tête
j'ai des idées un peu
occident m et j'ai des problèmes ici
autre élément qui choque ici pour une
femme zarka s'intéressent au foot alors
que c'est le cricket qui est roi il faut
que j'apprenne aïcha et zarka côtoieront
ainsi à paris des jeunes de tous les
pays du monde
invités par la france et qui viennent
aussi bien d'afrique ou d'asie
mais leur séjour se prolongera au delà
de la finale du mondial elles entendent
bien rester à paris pour le bal du 14
juillet et revenons à paris tout le
monde n'a pas la chance d'avoir une
place soir sur les gradins du grand
stade d'alors plusieurs écrans géants
étaient installés l'un d'entre eux au
stade charléty patrice pollet
oui daniel et bien écoutez nous sommes
tous au stade charléty davantage c'est
que ici c'est gratuit
alors depuis maintenant un peu près une
demi heure le public vous pouvez voir
derrière moi et à côté est en train
d'investir le site et le stade charléty
car ici c'est gratuit
toute la soirée en avantage ici c'est
que c'est un stade ce n'est pas l'hôtel
de ville par exemple et on est vraiment
dans l'ambiance de sport l'ambiance du
match qui va se dérouler tout à l'heure
on a l'impression tout à l'heure que il
va y avoir 22 joueurs sur le sadr
regardez bien sur la pelouse qui est
investi devant moi les téléspectateurs
vont pouvoir les pectoraux boire sur cet
écran à cristaux liquides suivre en
direct le match donc france croatie et
pour eux ça va être un peu comme s'ils
étaient au stade de france
alors à côté de moi j'ai un supporter
monsieur dit - exactement vous voyez le
sort a convié à combien disons que
les temps réglementaire et le but si tu
seras trés bien la faire pour les france
c'est à dire le mal le score c'est
combien un partout à la mi-temps après
prolongation et le but qui tu m'écoutes
et ça c'est le rôle et le sida dans
l'assistanat dos d'un mordu de la france
si on va voir le résultat mais je crois
qu'il faut dire comme d'habitude que le
meilleur gagne daniel merci patrice
pollet avec un nom comme ça vous allez
rester à regarder ce match il n'y a pas
que paris où l'aînée mobilisés pour
regarder cette demi finale de la coupe
du monde de football nous allons
maintenant à bordeaux on se prépare
aussi là-bas à une soirée coupe du monde
eric perrin je peux vous assurer qu'il
ya une ambiance à bordeaux à faire
rougir le le stade de france on attend
pas moins de vingt mille personnes ce
soir sur ce lieu quasiment toute la
ville s'est donné rendez vous au mondial
café sur les bords de la garonne pour
vivre et on n'en doute pas aux exploits
des tricolores alors si les supporters
au stade de france n'ont pas trop suivi
apparemment les couleurs équipe de
france ici et bien pas de problème pour
choisir sa tenue c'est ton choix bleu
blanc rouge bleu blanc rouge ou pour les
plus originaux bleu blanc rouge
parents enfants grands parents tout le
monde a fait le déplacement et c'est sûr
qu'on suivra avec vers des intérêts les
exploits des anciens girondins lizarazu
zidane et peut-être qui sait christophe
dugarry s'ils rentrent en cours de match
alors viens ici bas pour vivre un petit
peu le match com comme dans un stade
vibrer ensemble pour un événement vous
pouvez le voir c'est difficile de
résister à la bague à la vague tricolore
après le match en 1 concerne d'un avenir
en va de la musique brésilienne
un heureux présage on l'espère tease
pour une finale que tout le monde attend
france brésil
merci eric nour avons pour ce tatouage
dans moins d'une demi heure maintenant
elle est deux équipes entreront sur le
terrain donc et paris se vide petit à
petit ce soir et les supporters des deux
camps s'installe confortablement thierry
curtet quatre coins de paris pour quatre
façons bien différentes de passer ses
soirées les plus veinards vous le
devinez sont au stade de france ils pas
tous encore à sic mais aucune crainte
l'enceinte sera plein à craquer pour
tenir toute la soirée
certains préfèrent ne pas commencer trop
tôt les artistes deux ont eu droit à
l'escort habituel 30 minutes pour aller
de clairefontaine à samedi ils sont dans
leur vestiaire depuis 18h30 est aussi
contente maintenant l'ambiance montait
et puis il ya ceux qui veulent être de
la fête aussi mais sans billet gratuit
s'ils se sont réunis place de l'hôtel de
ville où stade charléty devant plusieurs
écrans géants à 18 heures ici ils
étaient 5000 à 21h ils seront au moins
15000 pas tout pêcheur
aux vues de thierry henry ici on n'est
pas tout à fait du même avis les quads
de paris préfère les petits comités qu'a
fait le tour sida dans le 20e l'espoir
change de camp
ouais
on va gagner et puis il ya les autres
ceux qui ne savent pas ou qui ne veulent
pas savoir qu'il y à paris ce soir une
demi finale de coupe du monde
ils vont profiter des champs-elysées
presque déserts enfin presque désert
jusqu'à 23 heures seulement si les
voyages
confirmation avec des images en direct
maintenant des champs-elysées que paris
est en train de se vider pour un
mercredi soir il n'y a effectivement pas
foule sur les chantiers ça devrait donc
convient de vous le dire s'arranger dans
la soirée en tout cas on le souhaite
pour les français voilà il ne nous reste
plus qu'à prononcer des mots de
cambronne pour l'équipe de france ce
journal est terminée au stade de france
on est en train de remplir les derniers
gradins qui ne l'était pas il n'y a plus
maintenant qu'à attendre et voir je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sur notre
chaîne bonsoir à demain